it is back folks the U.S will require
negative covid tests for travelers
coming from China after more than half
of a plane load of passengers from China
to Italy
tested positive for covid
does it work to require incoming
travelers to test well we'll talk about
that in a moment NPR reports U.S will
require travelers from China to show
negative covet tests before flight
um this will apply to Travelers from
China Hong Kong and Macau to show a
negative covet test before entering the
United States the CDC announced the
measure yesterday it will go into effect
January 5 for all passengers over age
two passengers must show a negative PCR
or monitored antigen tests no more than
two days before departure whether it's a
direct flight or whether you're coming
from another country if you go China
London New York you would still have to
show such a test even though strictly
speaking your flight is coming into the
U.S from London the monitor test must be
overseen by a Telehealth service
CDC is pointing to the surge in coveted
cases in China and the quote lack of
adequate and transparent epidemiological
and viral genomic sequence data being
reported from that country quote reduced
testing and case reporting in China and
minimal sharing of viral genomic
sequence data could delay the
identification of new variants of
concern if they arise so there's a few
different things that I think are
important to talk about here and one of
the things that I want to just remind
people when it comes to transparency
from China if you look right now at the
official reports of
um data from China China since the start
of the panda we're talking three years
folks China is officially reporting that
they've had only four hundred thousand
coveted cases and only 5200 deaths you
would have to be living under a rock and
suffering from serious confusion to
believe that these numbers are even
remotely connected to the reality of
covet in China another interesting thing
if you look at the official data China
is starting to report higher case
numbers but never more than 5 000 cases
a day and yet they have not officially
reported any deaths since May so it is
absolutely correct that the data we're
getting from China is bogus and if you
look at just a little anecdote the hill
reports nearly half of passengers from
China to Milan have coveted look at this
nearly half of the passengers on two
recent flights to Milan from China
tested positive 38 percent of passengers
on one flight and 52 percent of those on
a second flight had coveted there is no
way that the entire country of China
with a population of is at 1.3 billion
at this point 1.4 billion people there's
no way they have only four or five
thousand cases a day
and no deaths if half of two random
flights from China to Italy are people
who have coveted okay so a hundred
percent it is correct to believe that
there is a crazy amount of covid coming
out of China now the question is does
requiring entry covet tests work you
know the idea is
you require people to test to come in
you identify people who should
immediately go into quarantine
and hopefully you prevent the spread yes
I mean the idea makes some sense the
difficulties are many uh the supervised
antigen tests remember when I was in
Spain Last Summer
uh my girlfriend that I did the
supervised antigen tests where it's just
a home test but someone watches you do
it and my girlfriend got two false
positives and she was negative we ended
up having to find a hospital on a Sunday
Catholic holiday in Spain which I can
tell you is very difficult to do get a
PCR turned out she was turned out she
was negative
um those tests are not the most accurate
but not only are false positives a
problem false negatives particularly in
asymptomatic people are a major major
problem in fact when I had covet a few
weeks ago I was testing negative on
those tests even though I had covid
until I don't even know I guess day
three of my symptoms so the limitations
are
um asymptomatic people often test
negative on those tests
um it's not a guarantee you're not
infected
the fact that you can get the test two
days before travel makes it particularly
unhelpful the incubation period of covid
even though you know if you look at the
bell curve most people start showing
symptoms uh between two to five days
after exposure it can be up to 10 or
even more days so is that a reason not
to do anything no but it is a reason why
the technique may not be that effective
to be perfectly Frank
the most effective part of requiring
testing for people coming from China is
it might dissuade people who are
carrying the virus from even coming to
the United States at all uh but the the
real effectiveness of that policy is a
question mark I think is the point
doesn't mean we shouldn't do anything
doesn't mean we shouldn't be concerned
but we have to be sort of realistic
about that uh about that strategy let me
know your thoughts let me know if your
perspective is changing on uh sort of
like your risk tolerance at this point
and of course you immediately will get
the debate over this will inevitably be
what happens in the United States
because it's happening now in China
versus it might not be China has a very
low level of immunity as a result of
their zero coveted policy and so it's
not necessarily the case that what we
see in China is going to happen in the
United States remains to be seen make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
youtube.com the David Pacman show we're
going to take a quick break and be right
back with so much more to start winding
down 2022.